Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie ist die Stimmung vor dem Salon?
Die Stimmung ist an sich gut und die ist ein bisschen besser geworden heute Morgen noch bei mir, weil ich mir einige Lieder von Bill Ramsey schon angehört habe. Der ist ja gestern gestorben. Ein Amerikaner, der in Deutschland eine große Karriere gemacht hat in den 50er, 60er Jahren als Schauspieler, als Sänger, die Zuckerpuppe aus der Bauchtanztruppe oder auch Ohne Crammy geht die Mimini ins Bett. Auch dann ein Film mit Heinz Erhard. Und ja, ich hab den immer sehr bewundert, weil er wirklich eine außergewöhnliche Stimme hat und ein sehr guter Jazz-Sänger war und nicht nur ein Schlagersänger, aber auch diesem Schlager dann einen ganz besonderen Charme gegeben hat. Und das habe ich mir heute Morgen ein bisschen zu Gemüte geführt zu ein paar Bill Ramsey Auftritte.
Sehr gut. Dann kann ich kulturell nur anfügen, ich habe gestern wieder auf die Fresse gekriegt. Nein, ganz das Schlimme ist natürlich nicht, aber wir sind ja montags Badminton spielen, ich und meine Frau. Und damit es dann auch zu dem Ende kommt und nicht alle immer noch Lust haben noch drei Stunden weiterzuspielen, habe ich immer einen Rausschmeißer. Ich gehe immer mit meiner großen Bluetooth-Box in die Halle und dann bin ich sozusagen der DJ des Abends und ich spiele dann immer als Rausschmeißer Merci Cherie, allerdings nicht von Udo Jürgens, sondern in der Aufnahme von Helene Fischer, wie sie für Udo Jürgens zu seinem 80. Geburtstag noch mal für ihn singt.
Und er sehr verliebt und gerührt ist.
Absolut, absolut. Er sitzt in der ersten Reihe, schaut sich um, ob auch alle seine Leute das genauso geil finden wie er, geht dann auch zum Ende zu ihr auf die Bühne und ist eine ganz wunderschöne Aufnahme, denn ich bin bereit, es jetzt sagen Helene Fischer singt sensationell, sie hat nur das falsche Genre meistens, in dem Fall aber nicht.
Natürlich ist das Original wesentlich besser, denn diesen Ausdruck, den kann nur ein Udo Jürgens da reinlegen. Bei Helene Fischer ist es dann doch ein bisschen glatt. Es ist immer Musical, es ist perfekt gesungen, wie man das im Musical so tut, aber bei Udo Jürgens liegt der Ausdruck drin und das ist ein sehr kompliziertes Lied eigentlich. Also man muss sich diesen Text mal ansehen, was meint er da eigentlich, was erzählt er da? Welcher Abschied ist denn das jetzt da gerade? Sehr, sehr interessant.
Ja, also dieses Lied finde ich, also Udo Jürgens hat damit den damals noch französisch benannten European Song Contest gewonnen und ich finde manchmal, vielleicht kennst du das, ich beschreibe es mal, manchmal haben Musiker Ideen für Lieder, schreiben sie auf, singen sie dann auch, aber es braucht dann jemand anderen, von dem man das Lied interpretiert wird, um irgendwie dann doch noch mal mehr zu verstehen, wie es auch gemeint sein könnte. Also das andere noch mal aus Liedern mehr rausholen, als eigentlich schon drinsteckt und ich finde diese Udo Jürgens Aufnahme von damals, 1966, die ist halt wirklich gut und man, also Udo Jürgens, du hast es ja schon mal benannt mit, er wollte ja auch mal jenseits des Schnulzigen und so weiter mal über die Realität und den Alltag und es ist halt so ein Lied, ein Liebeslied, aber er hat es von Abschied handelt und ich finde mit dieser Gesamtgeschichte heute, dass Udo Jürgens kurz nach diesem 80. Geburtstag halt einfach gestorben ist. Er kam von der Bühne, legte sich ins Bett und ist wie der fühltigste Mensch der Welt.
Beim Spaziergang einfach zusammengebrochen, bei dem Spaziergang war es immer tot, ja.
Genau, aber es war ein ganz ganz schneller Tod und ein ganz erfülltes Leben, 80 Jahre. Und es war sozusagen der letzte Moment, um sich auch noch mal von ihm zu verabschieden, aber nicht im Sinne von, wir wissen, du stirbst morgen und du bist krank, also singen wir noch mal für dich, sondern, nee, du wirst heute 80. Das ist noch mal eine große Feierstunde. Wir erinnern noch mal auch an deinen Kanan und holen noch mal deine größten Erfolge raus. Interpretieren sie dann, finde ich, noch mal besser als Udo Jorgens selbst. Also ich finde, bei ihr kommt noch mal, es gibt also eine Stelle im Lied, die müsste man jetzt gemeinsam hören, wenn es um wie wild ist die Liebe und das Wasser und der Sturm und so. Und ich finde, bei ihr kommt es dadurch, dass sie es so musicalartig in Perfektion singen kann, noch mal deutlicher rüber als dieses dann doch mehr dahin, wie soll man sagen, es kann auch an der Aufnahmetechnik 1966 liegen, aber ist es zu schwach vorgetragen damals?
Ja, er hat natürlich eine Stimme, die stark an der Tagesschau dran ist schon, aber das ist aber eine ganz ausdrucksstarke Stimme. Mir ist Helene Fischer etwas zu glatt, aber ich weiß, was du meinst. Also es gibt schon großartige Musikschreiber, die aber nicht die besten Interpreten sind. Und ich weiß, ich mache mir jetzt ganz viele Feinde, aber ich traue mich es zu sagen. Ich glaube, dass die Lieder von Bob Dylan ganz gut sind, wenn sie von anderen gesungen werden. Bei Bob Dylan habe ich zum Teil Sachen, die er dann live interpretiert, nicht wiedererkannt. Ich weiß, das ist seine Art und dass er das immer wieder neu variiert und so, aber ich ertappe mich dabei, dass ich dann sage, es ist ein tolles Lied, schön wie Nana Muscuri das singt und das ist wieder eine große Stimme, die sowas kann. Ja, es kommt sehr drauf an und ich glaube, dass man auch das als gar nicht gering schätzig erachten muss, wenn Leute gar nicht selbst für sich schreiben können oder selbst keine Texte haben, sondern nur in Anführungszeichen Interpreter sind. Dazu gehört sehr viel und Opernsänger sind auch nur Interpreten, die haben auch nie etwas selbst komponiert.
Ja, also diese Trennung und jetzt sage ich was ganz fieses. Manchmal finde ich deutsche Filme synchronisiert besser als die englischen Originale.
Ja, das ist absolut so.
Manfred Lehmann zum Beispiel als Stimme für Bruce Willis und so. Das ist auch, wenn man dann mal die englischen Originale hört, gerade bei Bruce Willis oder auch John Travolta, fällt man ja vom Glauben ab, wenn man aufgewachsen ist mit dieser Manfred Lehmann Stimme und so weiter.
Bill Murray im Übrigen in Un-Täglich-Krüstes-Murmeltier klingt auch im Deutschen viel interessanter, hat viel mehr auch die Atmosphäre des Films dann in der Stimme. Und ich liebe auch sehr die Synchronisation von den alten Filmen der 50er- 60er-Jahre, denn da sind viele große gestandene Theater-Schauspieler, die sprechen das. Und da ist dann selbst in irgendeiner Schnulze noch ein bisschen Shakespeare drin oder ein bisschen Schiller.
Die sind ja auch schon alle hornalt, also hier Rupert de Niro und so weiter, denn einer der wenigen, die in der Schule großer Fan von Faust wurden, weil es mir einfach gefällt, wenn ein Text im Takt ist, also wenn man ihn auch lesen kann und die Sätze passen zueinander und reimen sich und so weiter. Ein bisschen kitsch ist ja bei Goethe immer dabei. Aber als ich Gustav Gründgens gehört habe in dieser Theateraufnahme dieser berühmten, wie er das runter rattert, ich dachte, das ist eine Missachtung des Textes, das kann man so nicht machen. Und deswegen sind mir diese alten Vertonungen, egal von was, auch diese alten... Also ich finde, mit James Bond hat es dann irgendwann begonnen interessant zu werden. Aber wenn man sich zu diesen, die Filmkritiker mal sagen, die 50er Jahre, das war die Hochzeit des Kinos von 50er, keine Ahnung. Wenn man diese deutschen Synchronisierungen, das ist irgendwie, nee, nee, nee, das klingt doch nicht.
Und da sind die noch an eine gewisse Geschwindigkeit halt, das ist noch Tempo bei Gustav Gründgens. Und ja, aber du musst dir das mal heute mal an den Schauspielhäusern geben, wenn die Faust machen. Die können ein, zwei Szenen inszenieren in dem Tempo, in dem die das machen.
Dann sind drei Stunden rum.
Dann sind drei Stunden rum, ja. Also das finde ich schon sehr gut. Es gibt auch tolle Hörspiele von Max Ofuels, auch eine Goethe-Novelle und sowas. Und das ist eine unglaubliche Geschwindigkeit, aber so präzise gesprochen, dass man trotzdem alles versteht und auch so präzise interpretiert, dass der Sinn transportiert wird. Also ich finde das nach wie vor beeindruckend und finde Gründkens ganz hervorragend.
Ja, Gründkens selbst ist ja total hervorragend, aber nicht in dieser Mephisto-Sache.
Die ist sehr übertrieben, ja, also das ist auch nicht so mein Lieblingsauftritt. Na ja, wir sind nochmal in die alte Welt geflüchtet und jetzt wollen wir aber in die neue Welt, aber in eine ganz neue. Also haben wir schon so ein sensationelles Buch im Salon je gelesen, habe ich mich gefragt.
Ich sag mal so, gehört zu den drei besten, würde ich mal sagen. Es ist ja so 500 Seiten lang oder so, ne? Die erste Hälfte spektakulär, danach franzt es so ein bisschen aus, wobei ich es sehr gut finde, wenn Autoren auch vielleicht gegen Lektor-Entscheidungen nochmal Themenexkurse machen, die ihnen irgendwie liegen, auch wenn sie mit dem eigentlichen Thema nichts zu tun haben. Im Finale, und wir reden hier über Mu von Parag, Kanada, im Finale stehen dann aber auch politisch ein paar Uiuiuiui Kommentar, habe ich mir drangeschrieben, Sachen drin.
Da muss man noch mal sehr fragen, ob man das will, also ob man diese neue Welt will, also das glaube ich.
Chip unter der Haut oder und so weiter.
Genau, also dass wir mal einfach uns an den Klimawandel anpassen transhumanistisch. Da bin ich auch sehr dagegen. Nur erstmal die Perspektive, die mit diesem Buch eröffnet wird, ist so sensationell, einfach zu sagen, so wir sind jetzt alle unterwegs und wenn ihr Europäer nicht aufwacht, aufpasst, dann sterbt ihr aus.
Also ihr habt kein Zuwanderungsproblem, ihr habt ein Abwanderungsproblem.
Ganz genau.
Hier sterben die Menschen und die, die da sind, die gehen.
Und das durchzuarbeiten für alle Kontinente und mal in zwei, drei Seiten ganz schnell die Probleme zu benennen. Ich finde das auch interessant, er hat ja dann Deutschland mehrmals als Thema, aber einmal wird es so deutlich, wie ist das eigentlich da im Osten dann, wenn da die Nazis sich zurückziehen und so. Und wenn er das mal so ganz schnell abfrühstückt in zwei Abschnitten, wie das dann sich da entwickeln wird und sagt, ja, dann gute Nacht. Also es ist sehr souverän auch geschrieben und mit einer Perspektive so von ganz oben drauf. Also dass man wirklich global schaut und sagt, ja, das passierte alles. Ja, fast über der Wolkendecke. Also ein sehr beeindruckendes Buch, eines, das einem zu denken gibt, wenn man sich anschaut, wo wir jetzt laufend darüber diskutieren. Also als dieses Spiel England gegen Deutschland war, was ich nicht gesehen habe, kam mir am Anschluss die Tagesschau. Und die habe ich mir dann zufälligerweise angesehen. Ich weiß gar nicht warum, weil ich auch die Tagesschau fast nie ansehe. Und dann war ich erst einmal verblüfft darüber, dass die Tagesschau noch mal fünf Minuten zusammenfasst, was bei dem Fußballspiel passiert ist, dass ja vermutlich jeder gesehen hat. Außer ich habe es halt nicht gesehen, aber ich wollte es ja auch nicht sehen. Aber sonst weiß es ja wirklich jeder, warum muss man es noch mal zusammenfassen? Und dann kommt danach direkt Annalena Baerbock und die Plagiats-Vorwürfe. Und dann dachte ich, also das ist jetzt das so Bedeutende, dass das in der Tagesschau gleich stattfinden muss. Man konnte natürlich auch gar nichts dazu sagen. Es gibt die Vorwürfe, es wird dementiert, bla bla bla, 30 Sekunden rum, dann kommt das nächste. Aber man fragt sich schon, was eigentlich da in Journalisten vorgeht, wenn man sagt, das ist aber jetzt wichtig für die Tagesschau. Also das war für mich ja immer so eine Setzung. Wenn man überhaupt in der Tagesschau mit einem Thema vorkommt, dann hat das eine extreme Relevanz. Und da würde ich sagen, egal welche Position man zu diesen Plagiats-Vorwürfen hat, ist das nicht so relevant, dass das was für die Tagesschau ist?
Nee, also wir lesen heute Texte im Salor zum Thema, was weiß ich, die Agrarwende. Dass sich erstmals die Umweltgruppen und der Bauernverband in einem Text bestellt von der Regierung dazu geäußert haben, dass ja, wir mit der Landwirtschaft die Umwelt zerstören, und zwar in einem Maße. Man kann ein Preisschild dran kleben, 90 Milliarden Schaden pro Jahr allein in Deutschland. Und eigentlich, und das sagt der Bauernverband, eigentlich müsste ein Kilo Gulasch 80 Euro kosten. Das könnte man natürlich mal thematisieren. Dass in Kanada bei 50 Grad, und das ist eben nicht nur so ein Deckel von irgendwelchen Luftverhältnissen, die alle 1000 Jahre sowieso vorkommen, nein, das ist Klimawandel. Dass es in Kanada jetzt schon 50 Grad sind, und wir in Europa auf die 45 Grad warten, die in Spanien schon sind, in Frankreich letztes Jahr schon waren, und in Deutschland sozusagen der Countdown läuft, ja, für das, was wir dann im Move lesen. Dass wir eigentlich alles mal umkrempeln müssten, unser ganzes Denkgebäude mal umwerfen müssten. Und dass dann die Tagesthemen, die Tagesschau und das heutige Schnell an einem Tag sozusagen die Munition aufnimmt. Und mit Munition meine ich hier wirklich nur den Begriff Plagiat. Zerstört von der CDU damals, CSU mit Gutenberg und so weiter. Der, der das alles losgedreht hat, wo man sich fragt, warum schreibt er eine Dissertation? Weil er sich das als Deko umhängt, als so Halbmilliardär. Fehlt ihm das noch, weil er sich das kaufen konnte, hat er jetzt einen Doktortitel. Der flog ihn dann um die Ohren, seitdem ist dieses Wort Plagiat einfach eine politische Waffe. Und wir lesen nachher Annalena Baerbocks Buch und reden auch mal über das Genre des politischen Buchs. Denn ich finde beides ist aus Gründen, die ich nicht ganz nachvollziehen kann, in Verruf. Viele fragen sich jetzt wieder, warum hat sie denn überhaupt so ein Buch geschrieben? Weil sie sich in Politik auch mal bekennen sollte. Und in deren Sicht ist das wirklich brutal, wie damit hier umgegangen wird, dass nämlich einfach nur das Wort Plagiat mit ihrem Buch in Verbindung gebracht wird. Und wenn man sich die Textstellen anschaut, das ist ja albern. Nur weil Joschka Fischer vor einem halben Jahr in einem Interview schon mal einen Satz baute mit den substantiven Putin, Russland, Pipeline, Geopolitik und sie auch Sätze baut mit Putin, Russland, Pipeline, Geopolitik, ist das plötzlich Plagiat. Da habe ich mir dann gestern auch den Scherz erlaubt, als Paul Ziemiak seinen Wir entfesseln die Wirtschaftsprogramm auf Twitter verkündet, drunter drüber zu schreiben, Plagiat. Das hat die CDU ja schon zum 17. Mal gesagt, dass sie hier die Wirtschaft mit Steuerentlastung fördern möchte. Das kann man denen nicht durchgehen lassen, diesen Unfug. Und so auf der Ebene sind wir jetzt angekommen. Und dass dann Laschet als CDU-Chef noch den Grünen vorwirft, Trump-Style Wahlkampf zu machen, weil sie sich so gegen Hans-Georg Maaßen äußern, also das macht das Graut dann fett. Das ist der Vorwurf, der Trumpesken Wahlkampfführung plötzlich aus der anderen Richtung kommt. Also das ist ganz grotesk.
Ich bin gespannt, ob du mich überzeugen kannst, dass es doch irgendetwas Positives an dem Genre-Politikerbuch gibt. Denn ich bin natürlich dagegen, habe glaube ich auch noch nie ein Politikerbuch in dem Sinne gelesen. Also habe mal ein Buch von Sarah Wagenknecht gelesen, aber jetzt kein Politikerbuch. Da ist jetzt jemand Kandidat. Und jetzt schauen wir mal, wie der so tickt. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was wir dazu sagen können. Auch zu der Frage, wie schnell wird zum Buch geschrieben? Braucht man dafür vier oder doch acht Wochen? Das sind ja die Fragen, die sich da stellen. Und womit vielleicht auch das eine oder andere erklärt ist, was dann so schnell zusammengeschustert wird. Ich werde ein ganz grandioses Buch vorstellen von KS. Comie Reddy. Das heißt Malavent Republic, A Short History of New India. Und das ist ein sensationelles Buch über das, was in den letzten 70 Jahren so in Indien vor sich gegangen ist. Es ist vor allem ein Buch über Modi, über seinen Aufstieg, seine Idee von Politik, seine Wahlkampfstrategien. Und ich würde mal sagen, wir haben das Buch jetzt zu spät. Wir hätten das oder bzw. wir haben zu spät nach Indien geblickt. Wir hätten viel lernen können über die Trump-Amtszeit schon vorher, weil wir das in Indien beobachten können. Und wir können aber vielleicht jetzt auch noch sehr viel da rausziehen, was jetzt gerade in Indien vor sich geht und wohin sich auch noch was entwickeln kann. Ich werde nicht über Heinrich Manns, der Untertan, sprechen, denn es ist so viel. Also erst mal das Indienbuch plus noch die Texte, die unbedingt mitmüssen. Also zur Kommunistischen Partei Chinas.
Richtig.
Und zwar nicht die Rede, die machen wir auch noch in der, die machen wir in der nächsten regulären Sitzung. Aber es gibt ein neues Handbuch für alle, wie die Geschichte der Kommunistischen Partei so ist. Und da hat sich ein Chinerexpert in zwei Interviews zugeäußert. Hochinteressant. Und wir gucken mal noch nach Indonesien. Wie ist denn das eigentlich mit dem Klimawandel, den wir alle so bekämpfen? Bekämpfen wir da vielleicht auch Indigene mit? Wir haben immer unsere CO2-Neutralität und so. Und wir müssen mal Naturschutzgebiete. Da gibt es einen sehr, sehr tollen Text von Katrin Hartmann. Und dann auch noch mal was zur Schuldenbremse. Beziehungsweise haben wir zu viele Schulden ein interessanter Beitrag aus der Börsenzeitung, der aber nicht Alarm schreit, sondern sagt, nee, es war eigentlich ganz gut gerade.
Das klingt gut. Ich habe ja auch einen Text aus dem Spiegel heute wieder dabei, eben schon genannt. Ansonsten, ich war ja in der letzten Woche, als wir den Fidden Salon ankündigten, ein bisschen verzweifelt, weil ich noch keine guten Texte hatte. Und dann hast du sogar schon gesagt, wir hatten doch schon, und habe ich nachgeguckt, ja, im März über die Epistemiologisierung der Politik gesprochen. Aber ich habe mal auf der Bestsellerliste nachgeguckt, was da steht, und ich bin ja interessiert an der Rentenrepublik, die auch einhergeht mit dem Gemütszustand der Jungen. Habe mir also von Zeyda, das ist schon der erste Fopade, der mir hier unterliegt, Rattikale Zärtlichkeit, warum Liebe politisch ist, angeschaut. Und wir gehen mal rein in die Blase der ganz wogen jungen Menschen, die, wie ich finde, aus ökonomischen Gründen völlig haltlos durch diese Welt mehr andern und sich jetzt fragen, wer bin ich und wem muss ich genügen? Oder darf ich auch mit mir selbst verpartnert sein? Und klären am Ende nochmal in einem anderen Text, das ist wahrscheinlich der kürzeste Text, den ich hier vorgestellt habe, die Frage Kunst zu Hause. Muss man zur Kunst immer nur ins Museum gehen oder kann man sich auch zu Hause einfach Kunst holen? Und erstens, was macht Kunst zu Hause aus? Was qualifiziert Kunst? Kann ja schließlich alles sein. Und wie kommt man zu dieser Kunst? Und wem sollte sie gefallen? Und ist Gefallen überhaupt eine richtige Kategorie? Und ist alles in drei Absätzen abgehandelt? Seid gespannt, gehen wir mal rein in den Salon.